you
[Music]
hi my name is Andrew bagel I'm a
researcher in the ability research group
at MSR and today we have a nice guest
Adam Barr who used to work at Microsoft
even as short as two years ago I met
Adam a long time ago actually when he
was in engineering excellence and we
were he gave me a lot of advice about
how to work with new employees at
Microsoft and especially how I used to
do studies to figure out how they
adapted to life here and I've had lots
of great advice about his observations
of that process before that he was also
part of Windows and he's been working at
Microsoft for in some capacity over the
last twenty three or so years so he's
got lots to say and today he's going to
talk about a book he wrote called the
problem with software why smart
engineers write bad code and lessons
that he has sort of picked up over the
what he what we all perceive as the last
big push in software engineering over
the last 50 years and where we've come
to and where we should be going and next
as well so thank you Adam please take it
away thank you thank you for having me
thank you for coming out so as he said
I'm at a bar and I wrote this book this
is my career more or less that I started
out of college a small company called
dendrite which you probably even heard
of that I came to Microsoft in early
1990 I worked on the first two versions
of NT I worked on an interactive
television project which went nowhere
eventually like most of Microsoft's
interactive television projects I worked
on Digital Studio a nonlinear video
editor at a company and Montreal they
were acquired that's where I grew up
worked on Windows 2000 also known as NT
5 there's actually a break in there
right there I actually wrote two books
once called proudly serving my corporate
masters which is about the first 10
years and then one was called find the
bug about debugging and reading code
which you're welcome to peruse after the
talk then I came back I was a p.m. on
PowerShell this result dev I was a p.m.
on PowerShell I worked in during
excellence for about five years we give
out these nice engineering Excellence
Awards no other logo apparently I
survived on the Internet
then I went to office worked on
2013-2016 and the next version for a
while once office started going monthly
shipping the year stopped really
mattering as much and now I work at a
company called cross lake which is a
consultancy that does due diligence for
acquisitions so if you're planning on
buying a software company and you want
to kick the tire it's just let me know I
can help you out so the term software
engineering was originally about fifty
years ago actually I want the subtitle
to look something like the 50 year quest
to turn software programmers into
software engineers but MIT press said
that was too long so I just made it why
smart engineers write bad code but the
term this this city on the left here is
garmisch germany so in 1968 NATO the
North Atlantic Treaty Organization
decided that they were concerned about
the quality of software used for
military purposes so they convened this
software engineering conference and it
was the first time that the term
software engineering really was used
commonly
so they got a bunch of academics and a
bunch of industry people together they
met they agreed yes there's a problem
with software we need to work on it we
need to make real software engineers
sounds great everyone away happy they
came back a year later in Rome and had
the second NATO software engineering
conference and they got into a big
argument with the industry people saying
the academics were had their heads in
the cloud and the academics and the
industry people just wanted to shove
software at the door and didn't care
about methods and that was the end of
the two-year attempt of a NATO software
engineering conference and that gap the
academic industry gap has continued and
grown in the last 50 years that is the
problem with software that I mentioned
in the book but there's a lot of other
good stuff too so one example is
language choice so this is the the Tower
of Babel meant to symbolize the variety
of human spoken languages you probably
recognize this image because in a
hallway near your office is they have
completed jigsaw puzzle with this image
on it but it's symbolizing the variety
of languages if we look at computer
languages
where they came from so the first few
languages came from academia so basic
was two guys at Dartmouth Pascal was a
guy in Switzerland the DTH and Al Gore
was actually a committee of computer
sciences who got together to create the
language then he moved into this phase
where research labs tended to invent
languages but that wasn't their main
purpose they had something else in mind
and they needed a better language so
Simula was a Norwegian lab which was
actually trying to do simulations like
traffic simulations and invented Simula
which was the first object-oriented C
C++ came out of Bell Labs again they
were trying to write better switching
software they weren't trying to create a
language but they needed a better
language and small talk Xerox PARC was
doing research on graphical UI's and
decided they needed a better language to
write graphical UI's so they camp with
small talk again it wasn't the goal to
sell small talk it was a means to an end
and now you have really companies
creating languages so the first two that
really this atom was objective-c and
Eiffel which were the two big
object-oriented languages that were
hyped now okay I'm not saying I was very
language but he was the first to put
that DNA well but the guy who wrote it
Meyer and by the way I I said hold
questions but you can it's really
terrible at the key thing was you had a
company iPhone that was selling Eiffel
the language and he was hyping
laboratory and software because he
wanted to sell eiffel and Brad Cox came
up with objective-c and had a company
selling objective-c that was the goal so
he was also hyping objective-c and he
talked about how we're gonna stitch
together objects like integrated
circuits on their motherboard and in
Bertrand Meyer came in with eiffel and
said oh yeah forget about don't think
about your actions think about your data
it'll change the world you know the
which is the fundamental object Orion a
hype and they were the first to really
like I said that was the goal of the
company so they tended to overhype
because they were trying to sell
software and basically everything else
is like that - right see shark and go
you know any java we're all companies
doing this to sell the language or to
sell a platform based on the language
right so their motivations were a little
suspect and theirs
in academic research about these
languages they're not backed by some
explanation of why this language is
better in this situation and that
language is better in some other
situation people are free to just make
outrageous claims about the quality
their language and how it's awesome for
everything because it's drifted away
from academia so what's what's caused
this drift this is a diagram from Fred
Brooks's book it's in the book the
mythical man-month it's not in the essay
the mythical man-month so Fred Brooks is
si is famous the mythical man-month are
saying if you add people to a software
project that's late you make it later
but this is something else he said it
was very insightful like most of his
book so at the top left you have what he
called the program which is what you
work on in school what academics can
handle a professor on a couple grad
students it's just a program maybe three
or four people work on it it lasts for
some short period of time and it goes
away it fulfills its purpose and fred
brooks said these things get complicated
in two dimensions one is you have a
programming system where you have a
software that stitched together by
multiple teams work and they have API
isn't have to integrate it and not
everybody can fit in the room and it
gets more complicated going down as well
when you have a programming product
something that's sold is maintained it
lives for years and years the people
working on it now or not the people who
originally worked on it and it's much
more complicated to work with
documentation and testing and
maintaining it and he said it gets three
times more complicated in both
dimensions so a programming systems
product which is what company like
Microsoft is working on is nine times as
complicated as a program but actually
Edgar Dykstra an academic and and
perennial source of good quotes actually
claims it's a hundred times more
complicated so he said it nice if I
could Ellis trait the various techniques
with small demonstration programs this
is in some book he's writing about
software and could conclude with and
when faced with a program a thousand
times as large you could pose it in the
same way this would be self-defeating as
one of my central themes will be that a
two things that differ in some respect
by a factor already a hundred or more
are utterly incomparable so he's saying
this top left quadrant in the bottom
right quadrant
although
both software are really very different
and then Harlan L is another this is an
IBM guy actually very well known IBM for
a long time leading software teams has
the same message its characteristic the
problems to be solved by advanced
practitioners require sustained efforts
over months or years for many people
tens or hundreds so this is the many
years and the many people right it's
both of the complications this kind of
math problem solving requires a
radically different kind of precision in
scope than required for individual
problem solvers now this is 1980 right
this was understood by people at the end
of the 1980s but instead of kind of
listening to this wisdom people went
searching for silver bullets this is the
lone ranger who's famous for shooting
his enemies with silver bullets just
kind of a signature move but silver
bullets are if you want to kill a
werewolf since we live in the northwest
might come in handy
you need a silver bullet apparently and
Fred Brooks wrote an essay called no
silver bullet in which he explained that
we hear cries for a silver bullet to
make software costs drop as much as
hardware costs but we've seen how silver
bullet on horizon there's no single
development in technology or management
which gives even one order of magnitude
improvement in productivity reliability
and simplicity and then a key point is
at the end not only are there no silver
bullets now in view the very nature of
software makes it unlikely there will be
any and there's an important point but
despite that the history of software
engineering these last 50 years have
been a search or silver bullets people
claiming that they have some technique
that's gonna make software simple and
make all the problems go away or at
least be minimized so starting with
structured programming which is way back
in the late 60s and early 70s which is
basically although it's interesting
every book about structured programming
makes great claims about how it's
awesome and then sort of confesses later
that they're not really sure what
structured programming really is but
it's gotta be really important because
everyone's talk about it but basically
structured programming is not having go
twos in your code like that's what it
boils down to
don't write assembly language in a
higher-level language and that was a big
thing everything's gonna be saved by
structured programming then we had
formal testing was gonna save the world
this is what our early 70s people
started talking about testing
four dozen the entire collection of
object-oriented programming which led to
design patterns which led to unit tests
which led to TDD that whole thing was
individually and collectively gonna save
the planet
agile of course is hype to the sky now
we've got functional programming you
probably heard DevOps again is gonna
solve all the problems you can tell when
you read a book about these stuff and
the prefix just makes these wat the
preface might be makes wild claims and
doesn't really have much content that
it's you're in the Silver Bullet
territory and it started way back in the
day this is a picture of mainframe with
tape reels to symbolize way back in the
day the structured programming actually
has an academic theory a formal proof
that you can write a program without go
to I won't read this quote because
that's basically what it says now the
code that results if you formally apply
this is actually really ugly and you
would not want to write it it's probably
better to have go twos then what this
thing produces but it actually at least
was an academic saying you know I'm
gonna show that structured programming
works I'm not just going to claim it and
then formal testing off so you had both
Dykstra the academic and Harlan Mills
the practitioner saying you can find
bugs the formal testing but you can't
prove that your software doesn't have
any bugs note the dates these is before
Microsoft was founded and yet Microsoft
embarked starting in I don't know in
1985 or something on a 15-year mission
to show that you could in fact prove
software correct with formal testing
which didn't go all so well but the
problem was Microsoft ignored the
history here unfortunately and many
other companies did too I'm not picking
on Microsoft I just happened to know a
lot about it but that was kind of it
where the really trying to figure these
silver bullets out with any kind of
research ended there was some research
people used to study programmers in 70s
people actually studied commenting
styling you could read these papers it's
quite interesting you know commenting
style do variable names matter there's
actually a theory that it was better to
have like random variable names rather
than ones that made sense because it's
forced you to pay more attention when
reading the code I mean maybe it's crazy
idea but people actually studied it
a little a bit experiments indenting
does indenting matter believe it or not
go-to people tried to study does is code
clearer which go to a nada there certain
cases where it's better to have go to
that kind of thing
again note the dates are all kind of in
the seventies but in Fred Brooks point
out this kind of died out so he wrote an
update to mythical man-month in the mid
nineties and he said he was surprised
how few of the things that he asserted
were critiqued proven or disproven he
wasn't claiming everything was right he
was just surprised that nobody really
studied it in any kind of empirical way
by ongoing research and experience and
so you get comments like this talk about
Hungarian notation this is in the book
showstopper which documents the first
product cycle of Windows NT coding style
Wars are a waste of valuable resources
although the confusion caused by
Hungarian probably wastes more time
so this is an unidentified Windows NT
three for one developer in 1992 it's not
me even though I was it identified one
of the NT developer in 1992 but I did
buy into this at the time few years out
of college because auntie didn't use
Hungarian so it must be be right my
current project was sort of my the thing
that was driving my thinking about
software and then you get to this does
anyone know what TV show this is from
mr. Silicon Valley and this is a Richard
breaking up with his girlfriend and why
is he breaking up with her
his house versus space is right she used
this TAS uses space and sorry he uses
tab so of course I mean obviously that's
a huge issue and Harlan Mills has a
quote about this long before Silicon
Valley he's not he's not commenting on
Silicon Valley there was no mathematical
rigor to inhibit these discussions some
became quite vehement this scene
actually ended with Richards Richard
throwing themselves down the stairs
although it's not really clear why he
does that so what happened we had this
studies people are studying go to is an
indenting and commenting style in the
70s and then now or suddenly nobody's
paying attention stuff anymore
well here's a hint from a quote from
Gerald
Weinberg another longtime observer of
computer science who I encourage you to
read so he's writing ninety ninety eight
he's talking to some programmers in the
mid nineties you say he's interesting
the coincidence that all of them had to
learn to program before they studied
throwing at me formally in school that's
a major change brought about by the
personal computer I had not even seen a
computer before I went to work for IBM
in 1956 yes there actually were
computers in 1956 but it's not a
coincidence this is the important thing
that happened the personal computer is
the cause of this throwing everything
away and of course a lot of the blame
rests with these two guys Paul Allen
rest in peace and Bill Gates
this is them at Lakeside in the early
70s learned to program teach themselves
to program and basic on some terminal
all connected to a mainframe they did
just a little earlier than most people
most people didn't quite do this in the
early 70s Mike the late 70s when the PCs
all the PCs came out with basic but this
is what happened they everyone taught
themselves the program once they had
access to a computer they didn't need
any instruction you need to take a class
to get access to a computer leaders had
a giant basic programming party right
about the same time Edgar Dykstra is
frantically trying to get people to stop
programming basic it's practically
impossible to teach good programmers to
students good programming to students
that have had prior exposure to basic
ask potential programmers they are
immensely mutilated beyond hopes of
generation so I just a survey who
learned to program in basic yeah so you
can disagree but I think it took me a
while certain to overcome my sense it
because I know how to program basic
which didn't even have functions with
names and parameters when I was learning
it I was a mentally mutilated might be
overstating it but I was slightly
damaged now Dykstra like I said Dykstra
just you know generates great quotes
constantly or did but actually that
point he really had a point this article
it's called how do we tell truths that
might hurt he's basically saying don't
program in basic there are better
languages out there and if you learn
basic first they're gonna hurt
yourselves
unfortunately its 1975 the Year
Microsoft
founded what was Microsoft found to do
produce a basic interpreter what irony
the result do you have a bunch of
self-taught programmers out there right
like I was self-taught and a bunch of
people at Microsoft now are self-taught
you may have gone a major in computer
science in school but you didn't learn
to program there right you you tie
yourself to program in high school you
kept doing that whatever worked for you
whatever crazy debugging system and
variable naming and all that and then
you kept going at that for a while
probably Microsoft until eventually you
might realize oh wow this isn't quite
working for these programming system
products like this bottom right quadrant
I'm doing top left quadrant stuff trying
to get paid to do bottom right stuff I
have to adapt my my approach but really
a lot of people are self-taught and
Harlan Mills again writing long before
Microsoft was found there literally for
Microsoft is founded when there maybe
would have been time to fix this problem
but nobody paid attention our present
programming courses are patterned
long-nosed of course in french
dictionary in such of course we started
the dictionary and learn what the
meaning of french words are in english
that corresponds to learning what pl/1
or Fortran statements do today to just
learn the syntax of the language I think
completion of such a course in French
dictionary we then invite exhort the
graduates to go forth and write French
poetry which corresponds to writing code
I think I can stop explaining the
analogy at this point of course results
that some people can write French poetry
and some not but the skills critical to
writing poetry were not learned in the
course they just took in French
dictionary so many self-taught
programmers happened to be naturally
clever people and can write software but
they're not taught that in college they
just haven't had that that skill and
they taught themselves they read a basic
manual like I did which has the syntax
but doesn't really explain anything
about why you should be doing this stuff
and Harlan ELLs again types and if the
precision scope are not gained in
university education it is difficult to
acquire them later
no matter how well motivated or adapt a
person might be at individual intuitive
approaches to problem solving so you may
be great in the top left box but it
doesn't mean you're going to be good at
the bottom right box the programming
systems product
so you may not know things you'd like to
know like what's the right programming
language to use people just tend to use
the same programming language they used
for the previous problem they saw what
to look for in code reviews what's look
for hiring right notoriously interviews
for software developers are kind of
random how reliable your software is is
your software about to fail use your
software obsolete so the vast majority
of software for example that runs the
internet and is the first piece of
software to contact a potentially
malicious network packet is written in C
because it's going to be something into
guts of Unix Linux or Windows and that's
like exactly the worst language for that
kind of thing because it's so
exploitable by design but it wasn't
meant to be connected to the Internet so
when you talk to a civil engineer they
can look at a bridge and say this bridge
is about to collapse and they can say
well if you do this stuff you might fix
it up in a last while longer
or maybe it's hopeless it's gonna
collapse no matter what that's what
engineers can do when you look at
something like the the office source
code base which you know I happen to be
work with for a while now I'm not making
any claims about the office codebase
being obsolete or not but it will be
very hard to answer the question is the
office codebase obsolete or not I know a
lot of work has been done to improve it
but is it actually being fixed up or is
it just you're painting a bridge which
is gonna collapse anyway it's very hard
to make these kind of statements cuz
there's not a lot of theory behind
software and programmers are just
contempt to use their own experience as
a guide right whatever they learned
about anything in software they're like
well works for me people are throwing
money at me this is great I've got a
career I don't like to think too deeply
about whether I'm doing the right thing
so Fred Brooks another thing he said
which I think is sort of symptomatic of
programmers so about nine years after
there's no silver bullet I say he wrote
a follow-up essay for a second version
of his book and he's talking about
people attacking the no silver bullet
essay said they mostly attacked the
central argument that there's no magical
solution and his opinion that there
cannot be one so they agree with his
arguments in no silver bullet but then
they go out and say there is a silver
bullet
for the software beast which is the
author the person complaining has
invented so the base is saying everybody
else is an idiot
but I know the answer I can solve a
software problem which is sort of the
ultimate thing a software engineer would
say this is Icarus the Greek legend so
Icarus was was stuck on an island
imprisoned sort of a long story but
anyway his father built made wings out
of feathers and patched them with wax
and yet they attempted to fly away from
the island they were imprisoned on at
some point I'm not sure this actually
really happened but but he got
interested it's not any flew too close
to the Sun and the wax melted the wings
fell off and he drowned in the sea poor
guy and he's asserted the picture of
hubris right people thinking they can do
more than actually can this is a quote
from Alexis Ohanian who founded reddit
but it for the purpose of this he's also
married to Serena Williams right
arguably the greatest female tennis
player in history so he found a rat he's
got a very special website thinks he's a
genius and then he actually observed
Serena Williams training to be great at
tennis he says I thought it was the
hardest working person on the planet I
thought we we software were the hardest
working industry that's what we tell
ourselves it's all malarkey I've had
this front-row seat over the last three
years to greatness it's a humbling
experiencing what it takes to actually
be that great so he is sort of realizing
he's not quite as often as he thought he
was just as he could crank out a website
and Gerald Weinberg once again pops in
saying the essential personality factor
in programming is a small dose of
humility and he goes on to explain
without that you'll be go for the
classic pattern of Greek drama like
Icarus that successfully suffer
confidence who are willing to blind
self-destruction and the idea that a
programmer can learn a few simple
techniques self-taught in high school
think you're an expert and then be
crushed by the irresistible power at the
computer or at least maybe that's a
little dramatic but you know have more
bugs than they expect
kind of thing and you might think wow
that's great but can't we just go back
to the simple days of writing code and
the top-left quadrant and what he used
to actually like writing writing
programs and the answer's no sorry you
work with Microsoft you're getting paid
to write the programming systems
products not the fun stuff so deal with
it one problem though is how fast it's
all happened so Harlan Mills noted this
in 76 that it's all happened in one
generation in the past 25 years got this
whole new industry that's has a critical
role in business in government had it
been spreaded over 125 years five
generations instead of just one you
might have a different history imagine
the opportunity for early industrial
development with five human generations
of curriculum development education
feedback for the expansion of useful
methodologies and pruning of less useful
topics right now you might think well
okay but it's been 40 years more so
maybe we've had that except remember we
kind of threw everything away about five
years after he said this because of the
personal computer revolution people sort
of ignored all the wisdom from the 60s
and 70s so we kind of started over we're
about 35 years into attempt to to
relearn everything about software
development and it's still basically one
generation you still have people
floating around Microsoft who learned to
program in basic on some janky computer
and that's where their formative
experiences came from it's like a four
ville right was running Boeing if he was
still around but aviation is developed
over a long period of time and all the
pioneers have aged out Orville might be
sitting there saying yeah I know about
those those newfangled jet engines and
you know maybe we should stick to balsa
wood or whatever if that's not happening
in a VA shion's but it essentially is
happening in the software industry the
people are still around the early people
who taught themselves are still around
and if you learned to program up in the
top left it's hard to adapt to
understand what's necessary for the
bottom right Marx that's actually done a
pretty good job I have to say now I'm a
software could sell them I go look at
companies all over the place and Mars
actually pretty good in their techniques
it took a long time a lot of painful
learning but actually they have a pretty
good handle on writing these programming
systems products at this point although
a lot of mistakes were made if you
wanted some fancy so this is actually
randomly I got I saw something Microsoft
redid their procurement site the
internal procurement site so I was just
looking for a diagram of a complicated
software component software system and
came up with this but there's a bunch of
p0 right there all stitched together
with API then it's got a bunch of
different modules clearly it's in the
bottom right quadrant and this is
complicated it's not just a simple
program and this is just an internal
procurement section for Microsoft right
it's not the world's most complicated
software and so but you have to do all
the hard things you have to you have to
worry about documentation and write unit
tests and do static analysis and all
this stuff and think about API design
it's a lot of work it seems more fun to
write small software but that's the way
it is these days in aviation they're
where the hero is this is Charles
Lindbergh first person to fly solo
across the Atlantic a lot of hero pilots
and the hero pilots did awesome stuff
and inspired people but eventually they
either from being a little too heroic or
just from aging out they were no longer
on the scene but you still have a lot of
hero and Microsoft went through a phase
they celebrated hero programmers which I
think they've mostly gotten over but
there was a lot of that that the person
in the corner cranking out code was was
revered and that's just not what you
need for real software development I
know I think I want to talk about is
performance so this is Donald Knuth
probably most famous quote Donald P with
another longtime writer about software
there's no doubt that the Grail
efficiency leads to abuse growl
efficiency meaning worried about
performance over other stuff programs
waste enormous amounts of time thinking
about or worrying about the speed of
non-critical parts of their programs and
these attempts at efficiency actually
have a strong negative impact when
debugging and maintenance are considered
we should forget about small
efficiencies say about 97 percent at a
time premature optimization is the root
of all evil not that bad is
the famous quote from Knuth now if
you're back in the old days you're
programming this thing which is an early
trs-80 model one so this had 4k of
memory that 4096 bytes not for Meg or 4
gig or whatever 4k it had a basic in ROM
that
so the basic was around but for cab to
hold the language I mean I mean the
program and the data the thing that you
could have 26 numeric variables a
through Z 2 strings a dollar sign and B
dollar sign and one array a four array I
guess but people actually wrote software
this thing you know miraculously okay in
that environment you're worried about
performance right it's like you know
it's there's not a lot of room but
you're also writing urine up in the
top-left quadrant right probably there
weren't a lot of large software
government projects going on in this
thing I was single people writing some
piece of software for themselves so fine
do whatever you want when one person is
writing on when one person is working on
piece of software you can use almost any
language almost any technique because
you'll know what you mean when you read
it especially if you're not using it for
a long time but people still like to
focus on performance because it's
measurable in particularly you can
measure performance if you're in a
top-left quadrant right any small piece
of software can be tuned and made faster
it feels like you're doing something
useful because you can measure it
measuring maintainability and it's my
API easily consumable by somebody else
involves dealing with with other people
basically not not really what
programmers want to do but but when
you're working on this stuff that's what
you got to worry about so it's much
easier to focus on performance you can
get this gratification oh look I've made
it faster and you have to deal with
other people but unfortunately when you
worked in a large software company you
have to deal with other people and other
people reading your code is much more
important than you
geek and out on some ran the performance
tweak that makes it harder to read and
even today I hear people say okay what's
wrong with today's young programmers
kids today and they'll probably complain
about perform
so probably say well they're all smart
and everything but they write this C
sharp code to manipulate a string and
they don't realize what's going on
underneath oh my god and I'm like that
is the greatest thing like that they
don't to worry about that they also
don't get exploited by random script
kiddies on the internet too which is a
nice thing so the fact that you don't do
worry about this you have languages take
care of these basics and memory
allocation is a huge advancement in
software and not some horrible thing
that people are ignoring performance
doctors talk about this he's talking
about goat cheese but he's saying why
goat cheese are bad but it's the second
part is important we're trying to
shorten the conceptual gap between the
static program and the dynamic process
that is you read a program spread out in
text space you want to figure out what's
going on in memory of the process so you
need to worry about readability not
performance and focus on whether people
can understand the thing when they read
it performance and readability are
opposed to each other this is the spy
versus spy guys from Mad Magazine which
may be slightly old reference here but
now I know people PI of some idea in
mind where okay there was an algorithm
and I made it I managed to make it
easier to read and faster and simpler
and it's all like performance and
readability were marching together hand
in hand but that almost never happened
they generally are opposed you start
with something nice and clean and then
you say oh it's too slow I better start
hacking away at it I'm gonna add an
extra parameter I'm gonna make the code
more complicated to handle some special
case I'll add some side access to the
data whatever and it just gets a takes
away from readability also point out you
could change the word readability to
managed code and the word performance to
native code and you would have a graphic
summary of a battle that raged inside
Microsoft for most of the decade of the
2000s between the dotnet API and the
windows native API over what is the
story we tell developers and the story
developers heard was I'll go right iOS
applications instead so this really
causes problems obviously you could
guess which side I'm on I think most
who's been
at this point in favor of of managed
code but people are making claims about
performance and readability being able
to be improved together that I don't
believe we're true
they tend to be opposite to each other
so I'll just clean up canoes quote
instead of saying premature optimization
is the root of all these I'll just say
optimization is the root of all evil hey
it's me this year now this does not mean
you never optimize right this is a
take-off on the quote money is the root
of all evil so that doesn't mean you
never use money you should we should get
rid of money it just means that money
causes problems and you have to be
careful about it so same thing I'm not
saying never optimize I'm just saying be
careful because when you have problems
with your software a lot of times it's
because somebody was was over optimizing
of course people always have excuses to
optimize right start out you're working
on some mini computer with small amounts
of memory then the PC comes along it's
got small amounts of memory the next
generation has these small devices they
have way more memory then these other
things but still ah gee it's kind of a
handheld I better start optimizing here
but just don't do it my father tells a
story of someone explained how do you
identify a tree in Oregon and the answer
is you just pointed and say it's a
Douglas fir now you'll be occasionally
wrong but really not enough to to matter
same thing with authorization when
someone says should I optimize something
just say no okay she'll be wrong but
again not enough to matter and if
someone wants to add a cache or
something just just like don't do it
i'ma get encash is a great fun they're
nice little top-left things you can do
when you can tweak them and oh it's so
much fun to write a cache but you know
it's just gonna collect bugs along with
the data and well now things are moving
to the cloud this is good because it it
clears away some of the grunge in code
because you have to deal with the
problems right you can't just throw it
over to user and they have to worry
about all the bugs so it's nice it
inspires people to write maintainable
code because they feel the pain more but
it's also there's some good techniques
here you know not I'm not throwing up
we're here claiming that containerized
micro-services are a silver bullet for
software development even though of
course some people are saying that but
it does when you start connecting
services that can scale independently
this is sort of the modern way to write
software in particular you can they can
they can work independently they're
connected by api's which are not these
ugly binary api's that are hard to debug
you can actually you can log them you
can replay them it's very nice you know
it's worried about memory allocation I
mean another aspect of this sort of
performance versus readability of people
who write code that obsessively checks
for memory allocation failures and you
wanted to put the actual logic is seven
ifs down over here and the barely fits
in your editor that's not a thing about
managed code people could just write
code that pretends that memory never
runs out I mean I know they don't really
do it they actually catch the exception
right and we do something when memory
runs out but reality is people just put
that memory never runs out which is
great because memory never does run out
and if it does and it's a service who
cares it gets restarted so you can write
cleaner code I mean a different senior
memory allocations failing and you
cascading up a failure versus throw an
exception which isn't handled is there
is no difference just restart to think
so eventually we will all be writing
software like this this is my claim like
even some game will be written like this
to be reliable and scalable even though
you might say oh but it won't perform
well but it's worth it to make more
maintainable code and you can actually
get to some notion of I want to make
this thing twice as strong I want to
make it twice as reliable because you
could actually handle it with
programming techniques which are harder
but that's what we need to move to the
quote from Lord of the Rings shortcuts
make long delays but you can't skimp on
this stuff you have to do the like I
said you got to write the test and you
got to do the code reviews and all that
stuff there's the same advice we're
giving and engineering excellence ten
years ago inside Microsoft
and if you're a manager then please give
your employees time to do this right
don't look at some schedule and say I
don't know I think I could do it in half
the time right because you're thinking
of the old way the grungy way of writing
code you're not thinking about modern
software development where things just
take a lot longer and there's a lot more
to do so Harlan Mills again this is 40
years ago so the next generation of
programmers will be much more competent
than the first ones they'll have to be
just as it was easier to get into
college in the good old days it was also
easier to get by as a programmer in the
good old days for this new generation of
programmer will need to be capable of a
level of precision and productivity
never dreamed up before now he's writing
in 78 and I think the next generation
which is my generation basically did do
that we were better programmers we had
better tools they're better techniques
we wrote better code than they did in
the 70s but it has to happen again
people always tend to write software
that's just about as complicated as a
human being can handle right so if
you're writing in assembly language in
1967 or something then maybe getting a
sort to work is like barely something
you can handle and now many years later
getting something like Windows to work
is again sort of at the limit of human
ability and we'll be doing more
complicated self in the future and
people have to like do more stuff that's
free more productive and hopefully we
can get academia back working with
industry again so there's actually be
some scientific backing to all this
stuff
I do encourage people to work with the
ACM and I Triple E Computer Society
which are industry trade groups and I
don't mean just people in research I
know research people in building 99 go
to a lot of conferences and and and
present a lot of conferences but I
really encourage everyday product group
people at Microsoft to also get involved
there's a lot of wisdom there you can
get there's also a lot of wisdom to
share like I said Microsoft actually
does a pretty good job of software
development and a lot of companies could
learn from Microsoft if you were out
there talking about it
which we tend not to do we excuse me I
mean you I don't work for Microsoft
anymore
if you want something to read besides
obviously you know my book I do think
these three this is basically Harland
mills his book Fred Brooks his book and
Jerry Weinberg's book are great even
though they're all old a lot of wisdom
still applies because it's the same
problems people had back in the day
Dykstra has some good books too but his
books tend to mix together something
insightful about programming with a
proof that a sort algorithm is faster
than another sort algorithm or something
so they're kind of a mix but these are
all good these are all about technique
and process and and management and
finally if you feel any residual guilt
because you're working for Microsoft and
Microsoft was founded to create a basic
interpreter and go pollute the world
with mentally mutilated programmers I
used to work in engineering excellence
interesting Axel's to shut down a little
bit after I left I think that's a
coincidence but I I wish Microsoft would
study itself more there's a lot to learn
we found that people tended to not be
interested in advice from other groups
of Microsoft because they could easily
understand well that we're windows in
their office and more completely
different so I'll just ignore that
advice whereas they take something like
agile which wasn't really relevant to
Microsoft in most cases but they'd like
oh this is great
so I encourage Microsoft to study to
look inward a bit like I said there's a
lot of wisdom at Microsoft that could be
shared and try to make up to the world
for creating a generation of basic
self-taught basic programmers and that's
that's my presentation of happy to take
questions
you can contact me on Twitter and you
can also get ahold of me I post
occasionally on Twitter but it's the
easiest way it holds me and I I'll
answer questions but first I want to
actually give away a copy of the book
there's other stuff is done the other
book but if someone wants to win a copy
so the question is I have a trivia
question that you have to answer so
that's a little old-school so Dykstra
has talked the the
was ragged on basic and saying that
mentally mutilates people he also
criticized for other languages that were
current at the time and the question is
can you name three of them three of the
languages that Dijkstra was also
criticizing yes in the back they're
close
two out of three still no not peskow
what's up yeah one well okay what are
the three tran peel one and Kowal yes
that's right foreign feel in a couple so
he did actually he liked algal algos
likes a pretty good language it's really
the the ancestor of most procedural
languages C C sharp all kind of come
from a level it's the first one with
what seems obvious now but if statements
with blocks of code after them which was
kind of a big idea then really the first
language didn't require go twos to write
decent code yeah so he Dijkstra was on
he didn't like COBOL Fortran PL one and
an APL APL which is I mean it's sort of
a programming language it's sort of a
cross between a programming language and
I and a cry for help but was actually
was a serious language at IBM you came
up with God knows why and and you know
he of course I mean make fun of APL is
sort of easy but but the text Ross was
pointing out that there were other
problems PL wons not bad actually I'm
not sure why I didn't like peel one
probably cuz he wasn't involved in
creating it and yet some beef with IBM
but yes he was against most of them
except Algol and of course C was being
germinate at the time but he didn't know
it probably so there were a better
languages coming along so there we go
Erica my former manager in fact ninja
excellence you have a you have won a
copy of the problem of software thank
you okay so I'm having to take questions
if anybody has questions on that and
like I said I have copies of the this
book any other two books while I'm here
if you want to improve your bug your
code reading or figure out what happened
in Microsoft in 90s
you're welcome to come up and peruse
those yes question in the back there I
guess you know yeah it's very sweatshirt
yeah
yeah so you mentioned the quadrants a
couple of times and so my question is
sort of about technical interviews
because in universities when we do
interviews we tend to ask questions
about that top-left quadrant right
and it seems like to be successful
you're talking about the bottom right
quadrant so what should we do about this
should we do doing interviews
differently we're looking for the wrong
or something else well that's a very
good question so I think that so in that
in a whiteboard interview you're stuck
in the top-left quadrant right I mean
that's all you have right you you can't
whiteboard out anything that's at all
complicated you know even something like
an API design you can talk about our API
API design maybe testing kind of get a
little bit into the other ones but you
do what ask people coding questions and
and they're gonna be small of necessity
I think what you could ask them though
it's about experience part of what the
book talks about is is I wish academia
would focus more on these bottom right
quadrant pieces of code in particular
there's tons of open source out there
now so you could just have a class where
you were hacking on the Linux kernel or
the Windows kernel is I don't know if
the state of open sourcing Windows is
but or anything there's so much open
open-source software out there then you
could have you could have people
modified and read large bodies of code
and try to make modifications and
understand different styles so I'm
hoping people will come out of college
having done that and then you could ask
them about you know tell me about a time
you had to consume a large body of code
tell me about how you'd approach this
talk about something you liked or
disliked and in somebody else's code so
you could match more experiential
questions about it because you could
bring up some giant source code listing
and interview and ask people to figure
out what's going on but that's that's a
little probably too too strict but
hopefully they would have experiences
coming out of college that they could
talk about I once did a I was in an
accident I actually had the ability to
ask HR to look through interview
feedback to see if people are touching
on the the ten competencies in Microsoft
had at the time one of which was
technical axel
and the others were communication and
cross team and all those other things
and like 100% of every single interview
had asked a coding question and of the
other nine competencies on average two
or three were covered at any point
during the during the day and the other
six or seven was completely ignored
during the interviews and these were
theoretically the ten important things
that Microsoft was looking for so I
think in coding it's good to ask you
don't it does not have to be about the
coding question you can ask about tell
me about a time you did this or worked
on a team or how to design an API or
consume an API and hopefully people have
experiences they can talk about yes so
you talked about Microsoft and sort of
best practices and I just think it's
similar to many companies which is code
reviews and testing and design and
documentation are there any good modern
books on this stuff I mean how well the
question is how well no and it like
you're talking about why they make
mistakes but how do we give our hammers
to do a better job well there's there's
um I mean a lot of books tend to be a
problem a lot of books is they talk
about something useful right but then
they they present it as it solves all
problems right so you wanted with sort
of overhyped books that have a core
that's useful but then they they
overstate the the solution so book on
unit testing will present unit testing
is a the answer to all problems when I
mean there's reasons you know there's
things you can do with unit testing and
things you can't do with unit testing I
don't know a book you know I actually
recommend what I prefer peel read is
there's a book called making software
which is about a bunch of empirical
software studies that people actually
studying software teams and saying we
observed them and they did this and they
did that and this work that's published
by O'Reilly that one's pretty good
empirical studies have sort of sort of
died out unfortunately people actually
studying programmers sort of
anthropologically there's still a few
conferences there's a but but that's a
pretty good one making software but yeah
I don't I don't know a book it's sort of
in an OBS kind of way lays out what to
do code complete a code complete to
Steve McConnell's book which is
you're 30 years old it's pretty good
it's also backed by research like he'll
actually say though the right length for
a method in number of lines of code is X
because somebody study it not just
because I feel that way unfortunately
his studies are all kind of old because
people stopped kind of stopped doing
that yes so you mentioned that you
believe today's generation writes better
software than previous generation core
writes the software better
any thoughts what we could do today to
prepare for the next generation and I'm
asking because I'm also working in a
team that well
yeah it's there I mean I mean that one
of the points is that but if you come
out of college and you haven't learned
this stuff and you've been successful in
college and you got a job Microsoft
let's say interviewing with skills you
tie yourself in in high school you're
you're kind of already thinking that you
know more than you probably do and it's
hard to change so I I think I wish
Microsoft would would go to universities
and say this is a curriculum we want I
think when Microsoft has done that they
focused more on specific skills like hey
you you should all be using Windows and
c-sharp and visual studio with your
classes that's not what I'm talking
about
I'm trying to get them to say you need
to work with larger code bases need to
you know teach debugging and teach code
reading like all this stuff that the
actual skills we care about without
without coming across is would you just
do our job for us like we're tired of
training people we want people who are
perfect when they come out of school
it's not gonna be like that but I wish
there'd be more closing this this gap
between academia and industry
like I said appeal show up I mean you
know if someone comes in and thinks
they're you know they're God's gift to
programming it's it's it takes a while
to disabuse some of that knowledge
unfortunately I mean it's something good
interview for you could you could try to
bias against
you know lack of humility excessive
hubris during an interview III would
think about that if they if they think
they're you know a genius at age 22
they're they're probably not and when we
come out to college like we go into
college and take the C s classes knowing
that everyone says you don't learn the
right skills for industry in college
like we're told that straight up front
so a lot of us do come into an industry
and we expect when we know and we do
learn a lot and we talk to each other
about all the different things aren't
learning so there are those kind of
people but they're also especially with
like the newer generations especially as
colleges are trying to improve their CS
classes they're not going to get
everything right there's only so much
you can teach people like not in the
field I guess I just want to say we are
training that's actually great to hear
and there are things you do get people
who come - who learned to program in
college right they show up they're not
the high school computer club graduates
right no it's great I mean I knew one
person like that in college it was like
what you didn't have a trs-80 or
whatever I mean you know what are you
doing here and I'm and I mean we did not
treat that person well also I you know
like looking back we were we were
obnoxious about it but but you feel like
hey you know I like I like playing games
on my game system I want to be a
programmer then there and they're just
come in kind of which is great and I
think people like that because they are
exposed to it at least a more formal
environment they're not reading a basic
manual at least they have some
instruction and some guidance tend to be
more open to the idea of wow I have
things to learn they probably still get
this mistreatment of the hardcore geeks
looking down at them so I'm glad you
made it through and are here but it is
something else you can work out just try
to make it more welcoming to everybody
yes so I have a question about the
viewpoint you take over there so for one
thing that's them assuming is but it
feels like generationally we've gone 50
years
even for a software engineering and it
feels like what exactly are we looking
for with such a silver bullet is it too
purple I ability bugs like I feel like
the goalpost keeps moving cos if
honestly if you did try to program
windows in the Senate language and like
today's Windows you wouldn't get very
far right so something was achieving
with all those extra like tools and
languages that we've created that has
improved the world right so everybody
knows that they have been achieve all
the silver bullets have value in some
cases right the phone with that thing
does have value you know structure
programming is better like DevOps is
useful in some cases it's it's not
people don't have the ability to discern
like when I should use this language so
they just write everything in Perl for
example you know which pearls a great
language for box top left box and it's
an absolutely abysmal language I worked
on a team some of whose members are
sitting in this room today that
maintained large pearled code bases in
Isha's to giant hassle but you know it
kind of grows like organically so I
think that the reason people search our
Silver Bullet is because they realize
that software is hard and they don't at
some point they realize well I don't
know everything and it kind of you know
any port in the storm kind of thing like
oh wow maybe DevOps will solve my
problems like that they'll be nice so
they you know they follow these you know
charismatic sort of solutions
optimization you can point to the tree
you say it's about this ruin you're
probably right so in terms of software
development though so are you saying
that I guess we're in the process of
developing software using
to thinking about education like what
kind of guidance would you give to
making the judgment call whether or not
to spend those time and resources like
implementing code that would only
actually really be used in education to
know that educators and really have been
very often
edge cases I've gotta talk about
pre-optimized basically saying well this
might run slow I better optimize it now
right I mean so in those edge cases I
mean my apply space would be would be
don't do it I mean I mean write the code
cleanly make sure it's understandable
focus on that maintainability and then
if it gets deployed and it's slow worry
about that you know essentially that's
my answer like it's so hard to know if
it's actually going to be slow and if
that code is going to be on the critical
path that messing it up just in case is
is not a good approach so my advice
really being don't optimize it right as
cleanly as you can and worry about it
later that's you know almost always the
right answer and when you're you're old
school manager says oh no we should you
know we need optimize it now then well I
don't know that's it that's a tough
that's a tough question the existence of
old-school people in the upper echelons
of Microsoft not everybody but floating
around the upper echelons of software
companies it's an issue because they
have they have the wrong instincts in
some ways because they're too old-school
yes in the back oh sorry got a second
question computer world is that there's
this there are two camps there's an
academic camp and there's an industry
camp and you talk about that separation
is part of the problem so right here at
Microsoft we have like we have the
research this workplace but we also have
all the other programmers working online
or software engineers working on like
future work in paints
what would you recommend like the things
Microsoft can do to make me pretty
psyched out do you think that needs to
be British do you think well I think I
think I think Microsoft there's enough
software being done at Microsoft that
research you know and even said thing
about how you used to study software
developers another like oh he used to
okay you know I mean I think Marcus I
wish research or somebody at Microsoft
agree
search would turn around and look at
Microsoft really try to synthesize some
wisdom about when is what language is
appropriate for what situation
yeah when should we get rid of software
and you know how do we analyze the
lifespan of a piece of software because
there's really a ton of software inside
Microsoft that you could look at without
having to go outside and look at
open-source so so I I
I wish Microsoft would do more that I
mean engineering excellence went away
Wow five years ago or something probably
for good reasons but it did we did lose
a little bit and the engineering
excellence wasn't really doing that as
much as it should have been either but I
I wish Microsoft would would think about
doing that kind of study going back to
your first question for optimization one
of the best pieces of advice I got given
by one P old-school programmers who had
changed their life do not optimize
anything right these simplest code
easiest to maintain we have profilers
that will tell us exactly where we need
optimized but we will spend far more
time reading this code and maintaining
it that we ever will
writing at this one time make it easy to
deal with in the future how many users
you have possess establish a product or
not because I agree with you if you
write new product you just do and then
you equate that one person objected to
me he said in Microsoft Word we
basically because it's one of the mostly
used software we hit every problems that
could be an optimization was hit because
it's used by so many people it will be
hit so more later but that probably the
only example I usually talk to my my
mind so the feature that my team
we had in the design phase we try to
think of different educators and we
didn't think too much about Italy we
didn't look seriously at the code
because like we put it in but because we
thought it was an edge kids mm-hmm but
then recently we got a lot of hot bugs
because turns out these edge cases just
like you said they're just so many users
who use them but you will hit that
educators at some point those educators
their edge cases for a reason they have
preference and then there are some edge
cases which we didn't even think of yes
I am the study I will tree first you do
Ranger look folks it depends on the size
of your project how many just you tried
together the morganson you see when you
can it also depends on your experience
based on your past experience sometimes
it's personal experience you build your
hands on something and you try to
activate one since the senior engineers
just have this intuition like their
videos been cooking for a while and so
they have a sense of body this is
probably what's gonna happen if we don't
deal with it now and therefore this is
what we should focus on not this thing
yes it comes from your past experience
and sometimes our strong it does yeah
you don't cancel iteration like that is
always correcting like the focus it's
not so I mean yeah yes you you do get
some incentive and also just you know
how to design things cleanly to I mean
people may be airing to design something
clean an API that's easily consumable
but they might do a bad job but if they
have experience you get better at that
sort of things so yeah there's value in
wisdom I'm not saying all old-timers
should be should be marched out the door
yes
what yes so going back to yourself or
engineering the fifty years and so
they're giving people like par Ness and
others who said well you know if it's
really gonna be software engineering
then where's the certification and I
guess another way to look at failure is
that we don't have such a thing but
there are certain disciplines right
where like safety critical systems and
things were there there there's a huge
amount of discipline and rigor I
although I think with IOT in medical
instrumentation were in danger of like
that hope and also be coming consumed by
maybe a hackfest but what but I guess my
top level is like do you think software
engineering certificate is worth
anything what would it sell what would
you know put what would you put it in
and our there disciplines where so I
think that we absolutely should have
software certification and licensing but
not today because we don't have the body
of knowledge the ACM was involved in
some projects put together by others
knowledge but it's really just kind of
like brain dump of ideas about software
development
there's no academic backing so I think
we absolutely should have software
engineering certification at some point
and licensing but we need to be nice to
set it as a forcing function like in ten
years we'll have it now we got to go fix
the problem but I'll have to actually
work but so I think yes we should be
licensed there's lots of things you
could learn and I mean even you know
security is a big thing you know it's
all there's all kinds of things that
people make mistakes they just shouldn't
be making because they're not aware of
the potential so yes I think we should
have it but people have pushed software
engineering Steve McConnell wrote a book
about about doing engineering licensing
today I doubt what I think would be a
mistake because there's just not enough
actual rigor behind what you'd be
licensed to people on so he license
people give him a test but they wouldn't
actually be better software engineers
that's a result and I'm looking for some
actual real wisdom that people could be
could be tested on before they were
licensed so
the theme of the divide between academia
and industry I spent a lot of time
teaching other students at university
and it and university professors are
easy to make fun of and they sort of
live in their heads in that Gardens
or some of them have part-time jobs and
they also work in them they do a great
job of helping show the in-between but
typically if you want to become one of
those people that can start to
disseminate knowledge at a university
you have to have stayed at the
University for a long time instead of
going and cooking for a long time and
actually getting your hands dirty and
building up the intuition and so now it
looks to me like you've got this divine
where the very people that we want to be
able to go teach at universities are
barred from doing so so how do we
approach universities what I mean I you
know we're not like I went to Princeton
and it was ready to Bell Labs actually
we had them several of my classes were
taught by visiting Bell Labs successors
who were not trained particularly as as
professors but they hadn't they had this
industry wisdom right they had been
working away at the switching code
whatever and it was quite valuable to
get their their input and then mix that
with the more theoretical teachers then
I know that there are some schools that
I actually really try to the terms it's
computer science and software
engineering are often used
interchangeably big schools call it one
or the other but there are schools
really try to teach software engineering
I know the Olin College in Massachusetts
is really trying to focus on that we got
to actually bring in some industry
people and like teach what we can about
software engineering so I mean I think
hopefully universe will start to worry
about this and more of them will say hey
there is a difference and there's
theoretical computer science which can
be useful in some cases
and there's software engineering and we
do want the interested people to come in
and we won't worry about do they have a
PhD or are they published or whatever
you worry about when you're hiring a
part of my father is a professor so you
know I don't have a negative view of
professors
he was a math professor but you know I
mean there is there is this focus not
academia on publishing and then and
things like that it's not necessarily
what's needed right now for for computer
science yes if what we know today is
like why do we you run a lot people in
in today's practices right out of school
as opposed to just you know encouraging
them to be I know
problem solvers and then just I don't
know what's what well we know today will
be proven wrong it'll just be shown to
be not quite as right as people thought
it was and I think it's also value in
basically knocking people off their
pedestal a bit off down a few pegs when
they when they were in school this
forest people learned something I mean I
basically sailed through school with my
self taught basic programming skills
right I mean I I learned some algorithms
but all all everything about getting my
code working and laying it out no it was
just what I figured out as a basic
program which is which is which is not a
good thing and so I think just teaching
people anything teaching a different
language you know like getting this idea
that oh wow there is something to learn
is very important just so they come in
open to the idea that they don't know
everything it's sort of like you know I
compared it to medicine like if someone
said I'm a doctor I didn't go to med
school you'd be like well that's really
concerning but you know if someone's a
programmer and they're like well I made
you to music or something which
Microsoft has people floating around
like wow that's awesome you know you are
so smart but I mean it's like just as
weird like what are you doing here
how can a music major be successful as a
programmer but they can because they can
they don't still learn much I think just
have a university curriculum where you
have to learn something and study some
stuff and like you know you have to pay
attention to your professors to to be
successful it would be very helpful just
to open people's minds even if the
specific skills aren't as as critical
canonical in the sense that they would
be industry people coming in and talking
about DevOps practices like I don't know
some random thing there that are
considered to be like you know the
current state of software engineering
and that lots of people in one so I mean
to be fair like the industry usually
runs ahead of where academia is and
DevOps practices are showing up in
classes there's like a startup classes
at CMU of how to do engineering if
you're in a start-up which is a
different set of strategies that you
would picture a more established company
there's DevOps classic North Carolina
State University on specifically
teaching fits out like University that's
how did you go why is that not good it's
it's like locking people yeah it's
teaching them skills that they're
they'll see and learn how would that
when they get to industry they'll adapt
to whatever they are going to be using
at their company but and obviously the
techniques and skills and processes that
we have today are very different than
those that students learn in school 10
years ago or 20 years ago or 30 years
ago and that's okay we don't wind
everyone learns through that what I hear
I guess my feeling is I'd rather have
someone coming in talking about DevOps
and not come in and talk about DevOps
because it's something from industry but
I well I really what should happen is
that academia would study DevOps and say
this is what's real and this is what's
bogus and then teach that but having a
DevOps person come in is like I said
better than reality is government
funding for academic researchers and
academics for the most part for our
researches institutes have to partner
with industry more and more there's a
downside to that but it does you know it
does help to bridge the gap I mean a lot
of a lot of academics can't you know
hope to have access to huge data centers
right to do research on DevOps in say a
data center cohn
thanks without like maybe having a co
appointment at Amazon or Microsoft then
you see more of that I think I think
there are some good parts of that so bad
but but I think the notion of the ivory
tower is is pretty dead these days I
mean to be to be perfectly honest I mean
you know the people who are doing theory
you know there's a lot more systems out
there so I think fundamentally the
danger of anything is like we don't get
the next great thinkers coming up with
simple abstractions because everybody's
sort of down it's working on our
problems I fear more for that actually
and I think magnetics are actually
studying a lot of open source they're
studying this law so I've a certain
field over the last 20 years actually
academics and oh that's gross
they have got yukari's me but I still I
feel Doug yeah I looked through
curriculums and stuff and it seems like
they're yo though they'll say what
industry is talking about they'll talk
about scrum or whatever but they're not
they're just sort of presenting it as
here's the thing you'll encounter
they're not thinking about the
researchers there's no no I've read a
lot of empirical studies books and I
make a big push for 20 years ago there's
it's huge anymore between like a third
to a quarter of the papers that you
would see of any academic South Virginia
conference there's so much more now I
think it's very used to being almost
nothing it's very funny
you know it used to be more you know 40
years ago maybe if this comes back but
like I said that make the software book
is in a bunch of empirical studies which
is great you know it is occasional but I
mean maybe we have different experience
have already seen but my stands talked a
couple of Terkel studies people and you
know they felt it was not it was still
kind of you know it was it was surviving
but it wasn't really booming you know I
talked to Victor Brazil he is one of
those sort of gurus of empirical just
like it's
anymore come you yeah and that's like
that's two generations
you should be poking the new kids on the
block well I mean it was around in your
retirement I'm just saying I think it's
a little bit introduced you know if
you're Pirkle size may come back that's
wonderful I thought a lot about a
vertical size in the book but I you know
haven't quite seen it may as much as you
have but that's good yes so one of the
things you mentioned was empirical
studies sort of start to feel old after
50 years so you people do these
randomized controlled trials the Dukas
EB tests and then about saying variable
naming but then they start to feel old
how do you keep these things fresh and
like how do you keep them in the minds
of I think you just I mean it may have
empirical size of coming back that's
great but you know you just have to keep
doing them right
[Laughter]
no I mean you just keep doing in people
if you recognize for it and companies
have to have to start consuming an
information you have to Microsoft has to
have somebody come from a conference and
say hey guess what Hungarian it's a
crazy idea you know or whatever like
which doesn't I did not observe that in
a product group anyway people coming
back from an ACM conference saying you
know hey I'd learned some about software
engineering so maybe it came to research
but it didn't cross over at least them
throw the group's I worked on my opinion
unit tests are to allow you to refactor
the code without breaking it that's what
you don't test do and refactoring code
is good so cleaning up your code is good
so you know test guard against breaking
your code accidentally regressing some
other random thing I don't think they
really help with overall software
quality except that when your code is
you're factorable
it can help with the quality but I think
there's a you know unit testing is not
and you know it's not automated
functionality testing but it's so
important because having a retractable
code is important so like don't throw it
away
they're cold because you factor cold and
we need to rewrite in a test that's what
yeah that's true and that slows down you
to three times yes sir that's right yes
but I think you just got to do it like
it's part of the software is slowing
down a bit because trying to be more
precise about it right no there's there
they're both useful for a different
thing right and user testing is to make
sure this thing actually works the way
it's supposed to work and unit testing
is so you can clean up the code without
breaking it you know I mean that they're
related but they're they're both testing
but I think you know Ted they're both
the unit testing is oversold as you can
get end user functionality quality I
mean I don't think they're that's not
what it's about
yes so in the industry now this is
really strong trade-off between being
able to write and should cook very
quickly and they're gonna start up and
the minimum or the maximum amount of
bars you tonight that a customer will
accept before switching to another piece
of software feels like the idea that
you're suggesting which is that software
development in order to become reliable
needs to slow down even further is and
the better comes the idea that you need
to go faster and faster in order to
compute the marketplace only successful
companies have the option of making
reliable supper well I mean I mean
you're right I'm biased in favor of more
reliable software and against you know
throwing something out there that to uh
you know to hit the market I mean so I
guess all right like yes a baby case is
worth you can getting something out of
quickly with lower quality is a good
business decision but you know just like
occasionally can build a bridge that's a
little rickety because it's for whatever
reason that's fine but but I mean again
that's more business decision it'll be
really nice if you could say I want this
quality level and this speed trade-off
and I could actually make some like
pretty reliable prediction about it and
just then it's just the business is and
surely versus kind of winding up with
something cuz you're in a hurry and you
cut corners like well I guess that's
what we're shipping because we got
customers lined up with you
that's not engineering at arguably speed
these days comes from putting together
systems rather than writing systems from
scratch that the microservices model
that you put up there that is a form of
much of the software that's written to
me those micro services don't take the
aren't a huge amount of code but you do
need to write them very carefully and
writing them slowly and correctly is
actually much faster because they
perform you create the system faster
from a lot of small pieces if those
small pieces are terrible you have
trouble no I don't think speed in
software development anymore is about
volume of the code I think it's about
working components of code that work
together with other existing it's
fascinating when we study companies now
for for cross lake I mean a lot of them
are just like grabbing open-source
components and I'm throwing them
together like hundreds of open-source
components and making software like it's
sort of turning this like assembly line
for a lot of it and it's just knowing
the skill is knowing what to grab not
that you know not actually writing these
complicated code for each for your basic
like it your database back website kind
of Ruby on Rails kind of territory it's
like there's not a lot of software but
again I'm not I'm thinking about more
like things like Windows and Office
which are big and complicated that's
what I'm worried about not some guy
putting up a you know a clone of reddit
or something I was sort of second the
comment here which is open source also
it drives out the economic incentive to
actually test your code properly because
you simply don't have the economic
resources so if you actually look at the
heart of some open-source projects you
know I'm just saying there are economic
incentives
a year that go directly against our goal
of building more reliable if you have no
money you can't afford higher testers
it's comes out and nobody wants to do
the scut work of spending like half
their time running tests for the new
feature there's something they write the
feature submit it with barely any
testing is no you're right yes their
economic incentives pushing against
doing things the right way I don't deny
that argument so all right JPL when like
the job propulsion laboratory NASA they
write a bunch of code too and so I read
a really interesting article where it
went into depth about the coding
practices and how they write software
for like space flights and space
missions like for devices that millions
of miles away you can't do bug that
thing like you have to write any get it
right the first time and so they went
through it and so they have extensive
documentation extensive testing a bunch
of theory in there too just to make sure
that because if the program goes wrong
there's nothing you can do and that's
like billions of dollars wasted and so I
understand that's a unique circumstance
but the article the point of the article
is really trying to drive home the point
that that's like the gold standard that
industry should eventually get to the
point where maybe we can also get to
that so like there are economic
incentives and especially if you're
doing a start-up and you have like a new
idea you to get it out before anyone
else does it but like there are it's not
impossible like it is impossible reality
that we could get to the point where the
way we do software development is as
rigorous and like detailed and like
extensive testing it like you can
imagine merely funneling millions of
dollars into making this device and for
every extra gram or pound you have
that's another like billion dollars in
jet fuel or something so those are
extenuating circumstances but I think
we're in a unique circumstance given
where the interest you have is right now
that we have really big companies with a
lot of really big resources that maybe
we could spare those like extra days
weeks or something - maybe I don't know
I'm just saying there are there are
examples that exists like currently
exist where they are more or less be
gold standard for the ideal case of
software testing so totally agree with
with what you're saying and I'd love to
see a variance of this doc or making six
ratings in stock were you go one
abstraction level down into particular
industries hmm because there's Stoppers
not when doing thank anymore so to look
at startups to look at rocket companies
to look at power companies plane
companies we see like how is it
different across those companies with
different economic trails in different
safety trade-offs Debbie a lot of stuff
is you know it is known how to make
reliable software people just don't
choose not to for a variety of reasons
economics they don't know it they don't
want to deal with it they're being
successful without it you know whatever
they tell me but there's a bunch of
things but yeah I don't think there's
like a it's not a huge mystery nasarah
how to write better software I mean JPL
which is where a lot of empirical
studies were done was like you know yes
they they knew they needed to make it
right so anything they took the effort
everybody's bought into that because the
project wasn't the right decision sure I
like to move to engineers to move to
engineering I think that the argument
was that well
testers are limited because they're
they're in this box you can only do
testing and and so a lot of people who
were worth like not able to do as good
work as they as they couldn't have just
reduced flexibility because as a manager
you couldn't move people around so and
of course most of the testers were
trained as software developers so they
could do the work it's over I think it's
a good idea it's more efficient it
removes some friction you have there
were issues of course some - didn't want
to write tests some teams just interpret
it as we're just getting rid of testing
and
everybody's right in code I mean so
there's there was some implantation uses
but yeah conceptual like the idea I mean
I think Deb should own quality not throw
it over the wall to a separate team so I
mean so so yeah I like the idea you know
like even if it wasn't necessarily
perfect in all cases I wish I wish more
former test leads had become the
engineering managers instead of
basically the dev leads usually doing
that even though I've you know that's
what happened to me but I was a deaf
leader became a manager but like yeah I
think it's a good idea for all this team
it's like half of the people actually
work on these four starts to supporting
the creation of the test cases and and I
don't play Google has created a world
where so thoughts they worried their
infrastructure team the team that's you
know does that stuff is somehow they've
created a world where that is valued at
scene is almost more important than than
doing the product work and I don't know
how they pulled that magic off but but -
just Google's culture it's like it's
like a a privilege to be allowed to work
on this important stuff that supports
other developers doesn't have that
culture and so I think as culture for
decades that effect disability do things
and so one last question I think back
here may I wanted to comment on it the
most convincing argument for me for this
unit testing and TDD silver bullet was
actually that the value is in
testability and not the test they these
tools that they provide and the
procedures are helping you to write code
so that you can test it testability the
value is not necessary if you have five
or 500 but now your code can adapt it
can change and that's I think the same
argument for micro services you can
all of it if you have tested it or not
if you're in a start-up and and write in
testable you might not have it now but
you you have a path forward to do it and
and so then that weird argument that's
sort of upside down is like you have to
write it in a way that you can adapt and
change and compose that that's where the
real value is and that doesn't like even
though that just a ticket old dental
ideas are longer I think that's that's
for me a big learning being a right code
so that you can test it that you can
evolve it if that's a separate
organization that drives this or if all
engineers have to have this that doesn't
matter it's that the methodology behind
the order the the tenants behind that
method is that dick-read no it's getting
the test done it's not just support who
does them
you